I will appoint Rock Solid constitutional
conservative judges in the mold of
Justice Antonin Scalia and the great
Justice Clarence Thomas who is under
siege right now right
he's under siege right now
for doing nothing he is really they're
going after him right now he's right
about Thomas is doing nothing he hasn't
spoken on the court for Allah everybody
else talked about appointing
conservatives to court I am the only one
who actually did it I appointed almost
federal judges all told it was
pretty substantially more than that a
record and three great Supreme Court
Justices so of course horrifying to hear
as we learn that uh Clarence Thomas is
likely the most corrupt and unethical
Supreme Court Justice in a hundred years
that Trump says we need more people like
Clarence Thomas